Hi
What's that believe nation, it's Evan my one word is believe and I believe n you
I want to see the thing that you've got
Inside here come out to have a big impact on the world instead of help you on your journey today
We're gonna look at six psychological tricks to make people like you
Immediately number two is my personal favorite and I left into which one you guys like the best and as
Always guys as you're watching if you hear something that really resonates with you
Please leave it down the comments below put quotes around it so other people can learn and when you write it down
It's much more likely to stick with yourself as well enjoy
So let's get into it trick number one is match and mirror rapport is power
Earlier today, we said anything you want to achieve anything you want to learn master
Experience there's somebody out there who has a life experience the understanding the network
The capital the thing you need to be able to achieve it
But they're not gonna give you what they want or they don't give you what you want rather a need until you first give them
What they want need and you're not even gonna find out what they want need until you first
Get in a relationship of rapport if you don't do that you're never gonna learn anything
rapport aspire
What is a relationship of rapport rapport means total responsiveness between people?
When someone is totally responding to you and you're totally responding then you're in rapport. There's that connection?
It's that spark that happens in certain communications or relationships
Now everybody wants to create rapport have it but most people only get rapport with people who are like whom?
Themselves, and they lose with everybody else which means you got a very limited world
So we want to take it to a different level
So let's say for example if I said to you right now guys
I want you to go out to a local restaurant or bar
And I want you to meet somebody and I want you to develop rapport with them a connection with them
How many feel like you do that no problem say?
I am and if you're not raising your hand you're probably selling yourself short of course you could how would you do it, though?
You'd walk of this restaurant a bar you meet somebody and you engage them in conversation by asking a few what?
Questions now is it possible to ask a few questions and have a conversation go boom just die is that possible yes or no
So questions don't create rapport
Questions or a tool use to dig for something. What are you digging for we ask these questions? You're trying to find something in what?
That's right, so write your notes rapport is created by a feeling of
commonality
Rapport is created
by a feeling of
commonality
Rapport is created by a feeling of commonality we people we feel like we have something in common with someone. There's a spark
Now here's the problem if we're porous creative affinity of commonality most people try to get rapport by using words
But you've already learned something what percentage of our communication skills are words what percentage
Seven percent which means you're leaving at 93 percent of your skills
Which is why most people don't get rapport with a large number of people
Yeah, what do you do you walk in a restaurant a bar and go hi? What's your name? Where are you from?
Why are you here and person says my name is Abbey? I'm from Rach. I'm a terrorist. I'm here to kill people
And you go amazing me, too
No
See words don't always work do they, but there is something that always works to get rapport
And that's something called matching and mirroring
matching and mirroring
Now matching and mirroring came about 35 years ago
When it's we've all done matching airing our whole lives, but the person who pointed out was Milton Erickson
Dr. Erickson was a genius
What he did was he was a medical doctor, but he also was a psychologist and a hypnotherapist probably the best that ever lived
And people will come to see him who try to change everything anywhere else in their life. Nothing at work
They see him for one session
he'd handle it and the reason is because he understood something he understood that you have both the conscious mind in his subconscious mind and
He knew the subconscious is more powerful
It's a part that makes your heart beat a hundred thousand times a day without him to think about
So he knew if he could influence your subconscious mind
He could change anything and that's what he did, but here's how he did it he had polio
So he was in a wheelchair
So he spent an enormous amount of time study people
And they began to notice something about human beings that when human beings got together if they got in rapport a relationship of responsiveness
They became like each other in a variety of ways what he called they mirrored each other
Now I've taught this for 25 years
I'm sure you've heard of it, and I've written in my books, and it's been taught in a variety of other areas now
But it's one thing to know it intellectually or to understand
It's another thing to know it what you're doing it, and that's what I want to get you to do tonight
So you have a real experience of it that you won't forget, but here's the basis of it people like people who are like whom?
Themselves and people don't like people who are not like themselves to be more specific write this down people like people who are like themselves
or
Who are like how they would like to be?
People like people who are like themselves or
or how they would like to be
People like people are like themselves or how they would like to be so question
I like you to think of someone you really really like a lot and
then if you would
Raise your hand if this person is either like you or
They're like how you want to be if that's true is you can say I?
Of course that's why I like them now think of someone you don't like
I'm sure you like everyone, but if you once were a nun spiritual person and felt these feelings some of you don't like
Raise your hand if they're not like you or they're not like how you want to be if that's true is your hand say aye
And that's the opposite people don't like people who are not like them
Or are not like how they want to be that's the bottom line of it so this concept Erikson noticed
He used it in the following way watch me if you came to see dr.
Erikson instead of talking to you intellectually and trying to get through to you he'd go right for the jugular
By getting your nervous system connected to him getting rapport so if you came to him and you said
Dr.. Erickson I
Don't know this is a waste of time. I've I've tried everything and I don't know I think I should just go
He would do this. He'd go
I'm sure it looks that way on the surface, but you haven't tried this so you haven't tried everything and I
Think you should stay
And the person would go Oh something about this guy I like
You know he's not over the top you know what I mean. He's like really real
There's just somethin bout him that feels down-home and real to me right if you came to see him. It's a dr., Erickson
I've tried everything it's a waste of my time. I'm out of here. He'd say you sit down
You haven't tried everything you've not done this before you're staying right here. Okay goes hey?
I like this guy's got some spunk kick ass. Maybe you could do something
See he became like the P blues communicating with and what it was is whatever they put out
He sent the same message back like biofeedback and didn't train them to him
So that when he didn't told their unconscious what to do their brain just did it that was his power trick number to?
Express positive energy I had to show up at work
with the right attitude and with the positive and and
I actually
Had a t-shirt made this and positive energy is a part of your job description
Right so the the idea that I want to show up with the right energy. I want to show
We
Have positive energy
It's just hugely important to approach everything and everybody at every turn with
Trip number three be loving and kind
Ever let anybody stop you but from believing that it's cool to be kind. That's the one thing I feel like that
I struggled with so much was that I?
Like to be loving and kind and people often will try to act like that's not cool
That's corny that all this type of stuff, but I my heart
It's like I've always wanted to share and be a loving person
And all that kind of stuff and that really stifled me sometimes as he as a young teen and I would really just tell myself
Don't stop believing that those are good things. Those are great qualities
Those aren't bad qualities it might seem like that because the cap type of people you around
But don't let that stop you from being true
You know the truth chick number four is have a sense of humor now primary focus should be palms on earth
but I think that there should be some small amount that's given over to the establishment of
of a colony on Mars and making life multiplanetary
That by small amount I mean some number less than 1% of our resources
So you know it's it's not as important as as say health care
But it's more important than like say cosmetics. I mean like I'm Pro. You know are in favor of cosmetics. I like them. They're great
But you know lipstick Oh colony on Mars
Question that has been discussed over the past couple of days should we be considering one trips one way only trips to Mars?
What's the best?
Approach to colonize the planet is it
But what's your review? It's not socially acceptable you think people will sign up to do it
I think there's plenty of people who sign up for a warrior to Mars
But maybe if I could just have a show of hands who wouldn't see there such an option I
See some not many or perhaps enough for a couple of missions
Simply enough I think it's sort of like is it a one-way mission, and then you die
Or is it a one-way mission and you get resupplied. That's a big difference
For the second option yeah exactly
but every I think it's so it ends up being a moot point because
You want to bring the spaceship back like these spaceships are expensive. Okay? If they're hard to bulls
And just leave them there
So whether or not people want to come back or not is kind of like they can jump on if they want
But they need the space you're back
Thank you
I mean kind of weird like it was like huge collection of spaceships on Mars over time really
Well if it's like we're just in the back and of course was just in the back
speaking of crazy things went went to Russia three times to
negotiate a deal to buy a couple of the largest ICBMs in the Russian fleet a
Strange experience
Get into that negotiation
Well you talk to people and know people and pretty soon. You're talking to the Russian rocket forces and
You know they?
Turns out Russia's quite quite a capitalist society
And and
So I've better but it definitely had some some weird meetings
In places like that. I swear. They looked like a Senate sanitarium or something
I don't know. It's just very hard we came back to the theme of crazy, yeah
Seriously this place had padded walls
Why do you have added walls it was weird and
Yeah, and then I had some sort of Russian guy we was missing a front to started yelling at me
Because his friend one of his front teeth was think it was like spit flying at me
That it wasn't like this really bizarre
Right and that wasn't what you thought. I'm gonna build my own rocket. Yeah, chick number five is embrace vulnerability
the biggest myth about
Vulnerability is that it's weakness. I think a lot of people were raised to believe that it was modeled. I think certainly in our culture
We see that a lot that to be vulnerable to be open to be exposed is to be weak
And the truth is you know what I found in my research is that vulnerability is not weakness in fact
I would argue that it's our greatest measure of courage when we went out and asked people. What is vulnerability we heard things like
Vulnerability is the first date after my divorce
Vulnerability is starting my own company
Vulnerability is taking responsibility for something that went wrong at work
Vulnerability is sitting with my wife who has stage three breast cancer and making plans for our young kids
Vulnerability is taking my business public you know
The definition I use in my work of vulnerability is simply uncertainty risk and emotional exposure
vulnerability is about the willingness to show up and to be seen even when there are no guarantees and
It's interesting to me. I mean one of the things that I thought was really interesting. I gave a talk
It's probably a couple years now, and it was being translated by people doing American sign language
And they came up before the talk started
they said are there any words that you're going to use a
Lot in your talk that we should you know know about that are might be different?
I said well use the word vulnerability a lot and they kind of there were two of them
They kind of look each other. They said oh we do this
For vulnerability, and I said what does that mean?
They said it means weak in the knees and then like wow that's not how I talk about vulnerability and she said well
there's only one other sign for vulnerability, and I said what is it and she said and
I said oh
That's what I'm talking about and so to me
Vulnerability is our most accurate measure of courage
I mean it's pretty powerful when I have 13,000 pieces of data collected over 12 years that I cannot find a single
incident or story of courage that was not completely underpinned by vulnerability I
Think the problem arises that if there are so many little paradoxes with vulnerability and one of them is that vulnerability is
Courage in you but weakness in me
When I meet you it's the first thing I look for in you, but it's the last thing
I want to show you and me and so I think
To really put ourselves out there
Knowing that if we do that enough we're going to fail
I just don't think it gets more courageous than that and trick number six is compliment others and last
But certainly not least is something that I do that is a little trick all right. It's like first impression espionage
because there's no getting around like in somebody when they actually give you a
compliment when I meet somebody for the first time I try to look for something that I can compliment them on all right because
Automatically you complement them. They like you more it happens right because when somebody you a compliment
You're like yeah
You just like a more it works gentleman
and then when they think of you next time they're gonna think of that dude who gave him the compliment that they
Automatically like gentlemen. Here's the deal first impressions. We only have one chance to make it so make yours count
Thank you guys so much for watching. I hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what did you think of this video?
What was your favorite trick and why how are you going to immediately?
Apply this somehow in your life for business leave your thoughts down in comments below
I'd also love to know did I miss a seven eight nine ten that you want to add to the list?
Share your thoughts in the comments. Thank you guys again so much for watching
I believe in you. I hope you continue to believe in yourself and whatever your one where it is much. Love I'll see you soon
The most important work ever if you had to think of one word
That's most important to you. That sums you Apple. That would be like a little beacon
Pay believe nation if you want to know what the most important one word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a very special secret video for you check the description for details